Yo! C'est Cyrus, on se retrouve pour une vidéo un peu spéciale, c'est le bac dans quelques jours.
Et du coup vous êtes nombreux à m'avoir demandé une vidéo spéciale pour le bac
Vu qu'on a peu de temps, je me suis dit que ça serait pas mal de faire une vidéo sur comment bien réviser le bac
... de philo!
Alors, niveau timing, si vous commencez vos révisions maintenant...
... c'est pas ouf.
Je vais quand même en parler pour les
personnes qui verront cette vidéo et qui ne
passent pas le bac dans quelques jours:
idéalement, vous révisez au cours de l'année
avec votre cours.
Essayez de privilégier le cours à parfois des
fiches hyper synthétiques que vous pouvez
trouver parce que c'est beaucoup plus facile
de comprendre avec un cours qui développe.
Et quand vous révisez votre cours,
il faut dégager le plan du cours
et prendre deux trois idées principales
par parties.
Ce qui vous permettra de dégager une idée
globale de votre cours.
Il y a vraiment deux grandes parties dans les révisions
du bac de philosophie: la forme et le fond.
Il faut vraiment travailler les deux et ne
pas en délaisser un.
Le fond, c'est le contenu.
Vous devez avoir une idée claire
de chaque notion, notamment grâce
aux définitions.
Et, ça ne sert à rien d'apprendre une définition
que vous ne comprenez pas.
Il faut vraiment faire cet effort de compréhension
de la définition et, ensuite, vous l’apprendrez
et, en plus, vous l’apprendrez plus facilement
si vous la comprenez. Ok?
Une fois que vous avez appris vos différentes
notions de manière très claire grâce aux définitions,
vous devez être capable de faire des liens
entre les différentes notions.
C'est ce que j'essaye de faire dans le Coup de Phil,
par exemple.
Parfois, à la fin d'un Coup de Phil', je dis
"c'est un petit peu ce qu'on avait vu avec tel philosophe"
ou alors "tel mec s'oppose à ça dans tel vidéo".
Essayez de faire ces liens là, ok?
Il faut que j'arrête de dire ok à la fin de
mes phrases.
Ok? Tu as compris? [rire]
D'ailleurs, parfois, vous allez devoir faire
le pont entre deux notions.
Par exemple, sur un sujet comme
"est-il absurde de désirer l'impossible",
qui est un truc que j'avais vu sur Internet,
je crois que c'était un sujet 2009.
Et ben là, ça fait appel à la notion de raison,
"cela est-il absurde?" et à la notion de
désir donc vous êtes obligé de faire
le pont entre ces deux notions.
Par ailleurs, je vous mets dans la description
de la vidéo, une fiche hyper synthétique qui a
été faite pas la page "50 nuances de L" avec Lozarey
et c'est une fiche un peu collaborative
où chacun à mis par notion ce que tel
philosophe pense de manière hyper synthétique.
Vachement bien. Je vous le met dans la description.
Il y a une prof qui disait qu'il vaut mieux savoir peu et
bien que beaucoup et mal.
Je suis entièrement d'accord avec ça.
Dans ce qui est contenu, il y a un truc,
je ne peux pas ne pas vous en parler,
vous le taffez sûrement beaucoup,
ce sont les citations, ok?
Alors, les citations, n'abusez pas de ça dans
votre copie.
Ta copie ne doit pas être un catalogue
de citations.
Parce que, en gros, si tu fais un
catalogue de citations, ça donne
l'impression que toi, tu ne connais pas grand chose
et que tu te reposes trop sur tes citations.
Donc c'est un dosage, c'est un peu comme la
cuisine, c'est un peu le sel:
si tu mets trop de sel, tu niques ta copie.
Ben c'est un peu pareil.
Enfin, si tu mets trop de sel, tu niques ton plat.
Parce que si tu mets du sel sur ta copie,
ça ne va pas la niquer mais ça n'a aucun intérêt.
Sauf si tu manges ta copie.
Par contre, une bonne citation, bien utilisée
au bon moment, au bon endroit avec pertinence,
qui est vraiment en rapport avec tout ce que tu viens
de dire avant: Boum!
C'est un peu le fatality dans Mortal Combat.
Genre [bruit d'explosions, de combat]
En plus, ça montre que tu as une rigueur
parce que ça veut dire que tu es capable d'utiliser
la bonne citation au bon endroit, avec précision.
La rigueur, la précision, c'est un peu ce qu'on
attend dans une copie au bac de philo.
Pour tout ce qui est de la forme,  j'en ai déjà parlé
longuement dans une vidéo que j'avais fait
il y a 2 ans.
Je vous mets le lien dans la description.
C'était une vidéo sur la dissertation.
Et dedans, j'avais fait aussi un renvoi vers une vidéo
sur le commentaire de texte.
Taffez bien ça.
Comment réviser la forme?
C'est très simple.
Quand tu prends tes annales,
l'idée c'est de ne pas lire le corrigé tout de suite.
Tu ne lis pas le sujet avec le corrigé dans la foulée.
Non, tu lis le sujet, tu essayes de te
poser à peu près un quart d'heure avec une feuille,
un stylo et juste développer tes idées,
voir jusqu'où tu peux aller dans tes idées,
voir les connections que tu peux faire entre elles
et essayer de dégager un plan, une problématique, etc.
Juste, en gros, de l'entraînement de plan
et de problématique.
Autre chose: ta copie de philo est
personnelle.
Tout ce que vous apprenez dans votre cours,
ça nourrit votre réflexion pour le devoir, ok?
Ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que
la réflexion seule ça ne suffit pas
et le cours seul, sans réflexion derrière,
ça ne suffit pas non plus.
C'est vraiment les deux qu'il faut mettre en avant.
Ce qu'il faut donc, c'est que tu aies des pensées
claires, donc avec des définitions, qui
te permettent d'avoir une pensée personnelle
qui va être structurée avec un plan
qui sera argumenté et nourris par des exemples.
Au niveau des exemples, vachement important:
essayez vraiment d'éviter tout ce qui peut être
polémique.
Tu ne sais pas qui va lire ta copie.
Si ça se trouve la personne qui va lire ta copie
est un.e gros.se rasciste.
Ça se trouve il/elle déteste la CGT.
Je n'en sais rien mais évite au maximum
tout ce qui peut être polémique dans ta copie.
Si tu veux faire de la polémique, ouvre un blog,
tu vas cartonner mais évite de le garder pour ta copie de philo.
Premier conseil: arrête de voir le bac de philo
comme ce gros monstre qui est difficile
à appréhender.
Non. Ça va bien se passer.
Si tu taffes, si tu prépares le truc,
il n'y a aucune raison que ça se passe mal, ok?
C'est possible, c'est faisable.
Tu vas le faire.
Ton programme de révision...
Il reste peu de jours, et même ceux
qui regardent cette vidéo plus tard
et qui auront plus de temps,
planifiez vos révisions.
Mais genre vraiment précisément.
Genre tant de bloc d'heures sur ce truc là.
C'est ça qui vous permettra de voir à
quel point vous êtes en retard ou en avance
sur vos révisions.
Généralement, on est plutôt en retard je vous avoue.
Et c'est ça qui vous permettra de prioriser
ce que vous allez réviser parce que
vous ne pouvez pas tout réviser.
N'oubliez pas aussi que c'est une période
de révision donc pas une période d'acquisition.
Normalement, tu n'apprends plus grand chose à
ce moment là parce qu'il y a trop de trucs
à apprendre.
C'est plus tu revois des trucs que tu as
plus ou moins appris dans l'année.
Ensuite, faites des fiches utiles.
Souvent, les fiches sont blindées,
avec énormément d'infos, pleins de couleurs
dans tous les sens.
Si ça marche pour vous, ok.
Je sais que la plupart des gens ça ne
marche pas comme ça, en fait.
Il faut que tes fiches soient hyper synthétiques
avec des mots clés, que tu ailles droit au but.
C'est pour ça que les épisodes de Coup de Phil'
ce n'est que 5 minutes parce que,
à la base, l'idée c'est un peu ça,
c'est de faire un truc hyper straight,
genre straight to the point.
Droit au but, en français.
Autre point, juste la veille, ne faites pas
le truc du mec qui se couche  à 3h du mat.
Mec, ça y est.
La veille... Tu fais ton programme de révision.
La philo c'est hyper important que...
On a bien dit qu'il y avait une partie contenu,
donc une partie savoir et une partie vraiment réflexion
sur le moment et pour ça,
il faut que tu sois frais.
C'est la première épreuve, si tu la commences mal,
si tu la foires, tu ne vas pas être dans un
super état psychologique pour le reste des épreuves.
D'ailleurs autre point: si tu rates l'épreuve,
stoïcien, c'est passé, ça ne dépend plus
de toi, concentre toi sur la suite.
Mais tout ça pour dire que essaye d'avoir
une bonne nuit de sommeil et d'y
aller serein au maximum.
Voilà, c'était quelques petits conseils
parce que vous êtes beaucoup à me l'avoir demandé.
J'espère que ça vous aidera, que ça vous donnera la
motiv et bon courage.
Ça va bien se passer.
Et surtout, une fois que vous avez passé le
bac de philo, que vous avez passé le bac,
n'arrêtez pas la philo.
C'est dommage de voir cette discipline seulement
comme un truc pour le bac, pour avoir une note.
C'est bien plus que ça donc n'hésitez
pas à continuer de votre côté avec
des vidéos sur Youtube par exemple.
[chuchote] C'est pour ça qu'il faut s'abonner.
Et dernière chose:
l'oeil du tigre.
[homme dans le film] Ouais.
Tu vois cet éclair dans leurs yeux Rocky?
Avant notre combat, je me suis entraîné à fond
mais je n'avais pas ce regard là.
Toi, tu l'avais et tu as gagné.
Il faut que tu retrouves ce regard.
L'oeil du tigre mec.
Oui, l’œil du tigre.